well the the set of global institutions
that we have now or all sort of left
over from World War two and they were
created for a particular context i'm
thinking care of you know the World Bank
and the United Nations particular the
structure of the Security Council and
everybody understands that these are
kind of outmoded in terms of either
their membership or their their powers
what no one has done yet has been able
to devise so here's the blueprint for
how we how we should fix all of them I
think the biggest issue there of course
is you have to devise a set of
institutions that are sufficiently
inclusive of the new power centres
Friday a Security Council which India is
excluded in 20-30 doesn't make a whole
lot of sense to me Security Council
which Brazil is not a player again
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
so one part of it is just reforming the
overall global architecture